our dr david aigus joins us now to sort
this all out david good morning to you
you know when dr fauci was here earlier
he said the calvary is coming i remember
last week you said listen you were very
excited about the pfizer news now we've
got news about the oxford vaccine
so moving forward what exactly does this
mean for all of us
well i mean it really is hope in a
bottle you know it's the notion that
these vaccines can prevent spread of the
virus
the critical question we don't know
about these vaccines
is even though it dramatically tempers
down any symptoms from the virus
are you still contagious when you're
asymptomatic with the vaccine
the oxford study that charlie was
alluding to is the only one
that actually was swabbing people every
week and so we will know that data
very shortly and if that data show you
were not infectious there will be a much
smaller tail to the curve and we're
going to end this sooner
in the united states i like the sound of
that the oxford vaccine back to what
charlie was saying seems to work very
well with people in their 60s and 70s
how significant is that
ah you know i mean obviously people in
their 60s 70s and 80s have much higher
likelihood of symptomatic over 19 being
in a hospital
many other complications and if it works
in them who classically have
not a strong immune response who we're
cheering for joy and that's very
exciting
the pfizer vaccine also showed a 94
percent
protection in elderly so that's exciting
that these are going to work in the
broad population have you seen any side
effects that concern you david
well what's interesting about vaccines
really over the last
several decades is that almost all
vaccine side effects are in the first
several weeks
in the first several weeks of these
studies we have seen side effects of
fever chills pain at the injection site
you know
occasionally fatigue but we have not
seen anything that is long-lasting or
very serious and so that's in over 90
000 patients that have been totally been
vaccinated so that's
very very positive a big story here in
new york we're going to talk to the
mayor a little bit later on but you know
the new york city schools have shut down
after a three percent uh positivity rate
in the city
yet the bars and the restaurants remain
open the schools are closed
does that make sense to you
well obviously the priorities are a
little bit strange but
you know the notion of an arbitrary
saying three percent
you know in the state of new york that
threshold is nine percent
and not saying in schools that are doing
it right with almost no infection
we're going to let them stay open
doesn't make a lot of sense broad
policies in today's world
we can use data to make targeted
policies for various neighborhoods
and various disciplines you know schools
are not the vector of spread right now
in new york city
and yet we're shutting them yeah we had
an interview with a little
girl when her mom said you're going to
go back to home for schooling she went
oh i think a lot of kids
feel that way how does it affect your
kids mental and physical health
and not to mention how the parents are
feeling
right i mean that's what i was going to
say parents also are very similar to
that child
you know i mean the children are
isolated many children can't thrive
educationally in those kinds of
environments
they're distant from all their friends
all the interactions are two-dimensional
rather than three-dimensional which our
brains are designed for
so it is really difficult for children
we have to think of the the cost of
doing this
it's not just blocking virus spread it
is the long-term
mental cost on these children that's
part of the equation
all right we'll be talking to the mayor
in our next hour in the meantime david
thank you very much